neither rain nor sleep nor totally
busted PSN will keep us from our
appointed live stream it's Destiny time
here at gamespot.com thanks for coming
and watching I'm Chris Waters here with
sha mcginness and Mary Kish and it's
Destiny Beta time almost uh for we've
got it fired up we've got three Destiny
betas happening currently
actively in the game Mary 84% downloaded
Chris 40% downloaded uh but so we're
going to build our fire team as this
stream goes on but as you can see behind
me Sean has just started it up he's
right here uh we missed the opening
cinematic but that's going to happen
again when Mary jumps in and then when I
jump in so we'll get to check that out
in a little bit but for now sha
mcginness where we at so we are in Old
Russia which is where the alpha started
but uh it doesn't actually start the
same way as the alpha did because a
moment ago what you guys just missed was
the ghost Peter Dinklage the ghost of
Peter Dinklage introducing himself ghost
dinkles ghost dinkles he uh he's
actually introducing himself for the
very first time so I would suspect that
this is the beginning of the story right
here okay as opposed to the alpha which
kind of just dropped you in like at a
certain point into still in Old Russia
though but yeah um I do want toow out
there that in addition to us playing the
game we also have Destiny beta codes
that we will be giving away to you guys
um I Heard uh as far as my sponses have
told me if you put anything in the chat
if you are just chatting away at us it's
the Gamespot comments I believe in the
Gamespot comments cu the Gamespot chat
servers are down because of sleet and
snow as I it's also due to Bungie um but
we don't have anything to back that up
so if you can just sound Theory put
something in the yeah in the comment
section of the gam spot tell us why you
want a code yeah we will give you a code
and it's redeemable for the platform of
your choice indeed uh and I believe uh
we have a a decent amount yeah so Untold
number that's in the gamespot.com
comments that's where you can win a beta
code or you can join us in the twitch
chat we're also watching uh checking
that out you can ask us questions uh and
uh comment on what you see going on
which is Sean being unable to summon
where we at what's going on well I feel
like this was from the uh like a demo
they showed at E3 or something this was
like the
first clarification on those codes PS4
omal we're getting clarification on
those codes they might not be PS4 only
stay with us for a sec they should be
for
platform uh but yeah I think he's
this part Sean does this I mean does
this look familiar to you guys no I feel
like this was the one of the first deos
they played or maybe this environment it
was just in this environment it was the
it was the demo they played at E3 where
they had a couple different people
playing the first time yeah you're right
it is that kind of same sequence where
you start in that kind of graveyard of
cars out in front of the wall like all
trying to flee presumably to get into
the wall it's the same flow but I when I
actually started out just now I didn't
have a gun yet and the ghost is actually
helping me find a gun to take care of
the fall in there okay so it's
definitely a different same flow
different context of the story I would
say and we've got the subtitles on so
you guys can check it out oh your your
site is all busted oh yeah that's
cool oh
vandals that'll teach you to spray paint
on municipal buildings eat it
jerks uh so what is this like an assault
rifle you got here yeah more of an lmg
what would you say this looks like it
feels like an assault
rifle I one to M oh that was 4 two that
was good timing wasn't it all right the
dude just appeared in front of your
punch attack oh yeah that was uh wrong
place wrong time for that jerk uh so you
notice that punch attack was the kind of
like energy blast thing denoting that
Shawn is playing the Warlock class
that's one of three classes in Destiny
the other two being Titan and Hunter or
shark Marksman thing I don't know shark
shark Marksman Shar Marksman yeah
definitely shark Marksman as you just
said Chris what's the classes the
different so uh Titan is kind of a tank
okay warlock is the space wizard he's
the Mage and Hunter is kind of the Rogue
okay um which one did you go for I want
warlock okay so that leaves two left
yeah it's going to be your choice your
download is at 85% mine's at 44% so
you're going to get to shoes you're
getting the scraps chip mines don't
touch them
okay okay so it is for platform of your
choice but if you choose Xbox you won't
actually be able to play for another
week that is that is the truth that we
have heard to reiterate we're giving
away codes to the Destiny Beta comment
in the Gamespot comments let us know why
you want a code then we'll send you one
you'll be able to redeem it for PS3 PS4
Xbox 360 Xbox one it's going to be your
choice however the Xbox one and Xbox 360
beta doesn't start for about another
week or so or so uh so just keep that in
mind when you're choosing uh if you have
the option that's correct so yeah
definitely throw out some questions in
the games spot chat um I'm also in the
chat and I'm able to uh ask I'm I can uh
tell your questions and we'll answer
them here so send them our way it is
getting hot all right so it's getting
hot in here oh they got little booby
traps yeah that's neat did they throw
those down or were they there when you
came into this area those appear to have
been there when we enter this area now
all right so the health I played the
alpha only a little bit here uh let's
talk about the HUD for a second cuz at
the bottom here right by our faces which
are scooting around you see the sort of
a a one that's your level the green bar
at the bottom bar down there when you
were getting injured there was a a
health bar that got pretty red cuz you
were getting your butt a little whooped
there it is yeah the top is that just a
monolithic health bar there's no Shield
health you'll see there's little lines
there you see those two lines and I
think it'll like recharge differently
depending on which threshold that you've
crossed um okay like it'll take a little
bit longer to come back from yeah like
if you if you only lose a little bit
from that first one it'll recharge all
the way but if you get down into that
second one maybe it'll recharge the
second one more quickly and then that
third one will take a a little bit
longer that's my that's what I I think I
could be wrong well we shall observe if
you're in the chat feel free to correct
us I'm sure you will correct us on a
great many things the chat is at
twitch.tv/ Gamespot we're also checking
out the comments on Gamespot and it's
the comments where you're going to be
able to enter to win a code that's true
not in the chat correct all right good
to
know your Dar indicates that there's
some some dudes still around are there
still an amount of
dudes so you
one of the primary differences and
between the
classes actually I don't hear what
dinkle bot says dinkle ghost ghost
dinkle what do we decide to call them
just dinkle dinkle uh we're all getting
dled right now one of the primary
differences between the classes of
course they're like super move or
special ability whatever they call it
which you have actually don't have
access to yet right you got to like I'm
doing my double click and no you got to
you got to level up to get that as the
Warlock this was an old Cosmo drone
there's got to be something we can fly
out of here osmo drone that's cool that
looks cool that flare is probably not
good news for you incoming no no bad
news what's that I mean there's going to
be a just a little
minor with some some Fallen maybe
showing up I'm going to Pilot this tank
all right get in the tank get in the
tank get in the MBT it's main battle
tank time what is that is that a ship
that looks like a big nasty ship that's
mother
dinkle wow look Fallen ships this close
to the surface dle is
a I think guys we got to do a sweet Swan
Dive off the end of the tank yeah you
like
that oh yeah they're dropping them yeah
they're dropping it like it's hot
they're coming at you
now come on brother get
dead I see you
jerks oh I love that head shot so much
was it it it's just like cuz it creates
that little like white wisp of like the
soul escaping through their neck hole
Yeah it's like steam violently escaping
from their neck it's a cool it's kind of
a cool visual
effect that guy's name Doug Doug no I
think it says drg but we're going to
call them Dougs from now on Doug there's
nothing funny about that Doug got a
whole pack of Dougs Dougs and Vinnies
cuz the Vandals right Dougs and Vinnies
yeah we've got code names for them I
mean that's what all good soldiers have
I mean in World War II the Germans were
jerries exactly so it only makes sense
yeah that's devastating devastating you
don't like that Mary no Mary not a fan
if you want to propose alternate
nicknames I'm all
ears it's
like so Humanity to name them Doug dreg
I don't care about that guy nobody
we're trying to humanize our enemies so
that every every kill you're making War
too real for me you want a little bit
more to enjoy this
please right in the dug head no right in
the
Dugger teach me how to dugie teach me
how I'll teach you how to dugey oh that
guy got dugged no lights out dug how do
you get dug you well you are dug and
then you dug somebody I don't no listen
I don't know I'm just flapping my gun
working it out here it's in beta makes
any
sense how's your guys' download going
I'm at
87% all right so you're actually
climbing faster than I am cuz I've been
on 80 for Like O 20 minutes you have
been on in the 80 range for a while I'm
on 49 now let's find us a safe spot so
I'm at like it's a 10.97 gigabyte
download so the way you it works is you
I don't know never mind it's boring are
you talking about putting it you get a
you get a n digigit code and you have to
go to bungie.net to put your code and
you have to um L you have to log into
your account or create one yeah put in
your code and then you get a code from
that that is that you can put into PSN
so on the subject of supers on the
subject of or actually no this is just a
grenade AB super sorry so you got a
Grenade yeah uh now did the classes have
different grenades by default I don't
remember actually well we'll find out
we will so some of the things that I
haven't unlocked yet is like that really
cool Glide jump remember that from the
alpha Nova bomb which is actually my uh
my
super an explosive bolt void light yeah
is that your alt that's my Alti that's
your that's pretty good uh but yeah the
grenades in this game are on a cool down
they're not uh I'm pick pick up grenades
although you do have to pick up
ammunition for your primary and
secondary uh let's see that shotgun in
action mckinness want to see shotty yeah
let's get let's get shotty with it let's
get up close and personal man it is it
is the screen is so dark with all the
lights in the studio yeah no it's it's a
f I'm looking at the the live feed it's
a fine okay uh it looks fine for the
folk it's not as not the Shadows aren't
nearly as dark for folks at all that's
good that's good oh what up Doug hey
Doug oh no l a Doug party oh what kind
of Doug party is this a dead doug party
dead doug dead doug watch this guy blap
no you get flapped perhaps you didn't
hear me the first
time oh cute knife Doug now you don't
have a head anymore how does that feel
that's so Doug to bring a knife to a
gunfight classic Doug classic Doug move
a all right we're going slightly ranged
here there's a ship clear him out oh you
can get that ship you guys like nades
there's a devil
Captain that's wrong the the devil
Captain Ron the devil Captain he appears
to have a shield
shot we got a rogue Doug is that a video
Rogue movie video movie a moving picture
yeah is that a moving picture what am I
thinking of is that one of those
Takis Bad Dudes at there's Captain Ron
all right I got to take care of these
dogs before I take care of Captain
Ron and they've got those little drones
they're called Shanks you're going to
step directly on grenade
whoa top tip going to dug you going to
dug from the game going to oh you're
moving back wish I could dug you but I
can't wish I could dug you girl teach
him how to dugy all right going to let
the health recharge and then I'm going
to make a move on Ron yeah so it did I
was watching the health it did quickly
recharge to that first bar get and then
took a second and then recharged fully
all the way do you have a shield on top
of your health
bar not currently so not that I know of
no I think it's just a single health bar
oh look at you wow you look you're
looking shabby been here a
while hasn't made a jump in
centuries we're lucky the Fallen hav
completely picked it
cleav will it
fly I can make it
work are arguing about whether it's beta
or
beta which country is that the first
time we heard the player voice y these
uh outside the character cinematics are
not something that appeared in the
alpha so all this kind of like
storytelling cinematic stuff is first
time I've seen it yeah dinkle making
your ship F it's not going to break
orbit it just might get us to the city
now about that
transpant the
lady
that guy bringing you in oh sorry jerk
we're going to bounce yeah I'm going to
peace out you're such a coward John what
that guy just got
you
jerks everyone says this game's like
Halo but it's really like GTA because
you're stealing rides stealing rides
left
the nice nice job you got some precise
kills which is what like a head shot 53
kills 19 precise kills ability kills 10
vague kills that's probably like a punch
attack um or grenade maybe Mission
summary
says yeah took me 14 minutes 38 seconds
all right Moving On Moving On Up dang
Mary your download is hella slow I went
10% in the time it took you to go 1%
well that happened to me too and then I
went to a slow crawl slow Zone Fair
Dinkum Fair how's our chat doing right
now chatting it up once again if you
guys are just tuning in we're playing
the Destiny Beta here on gamespot.com
yeah one of us is the other two are
currently downloading it we got a 54
percenter and a
89er uh currently you're
faer I'm coming along and I have a B+ so
and we're also giving away codes so
don't forget to leave a comment in The
Game Spot Destiny now playing chat uh in
the comments section that way you're
entered to win a code for the console of
your choice ha all right we're watching
cinematics that you can also be a part
of watching the percent go up so this is
the city where the which is the like
lone Outpost protected by the traveler
on Earth that huge Dome thing is the
traveler which is maybe
dead traveler is kind of it's It's kind
of its role in the story is mysterious
welcome to the and by that I mean I
don't exactly know what it role is the
traveler can still
protect it took centuries to
build now we're counting every day at
stands first look at Sean's character
model choices and this Tower is where
the
Guardians so as in the alpha I'm
guessing right now we're going to go
into the third person sort of
exploration of a non-c combat zone
mode you're going to have to show off
your look Sean from your character
creation show off my look step one your
sweet dance move my sweet dance don't
worry about that those are coming
oo and then do whatever else you know I
don't know game I want to see from a
third person perspective oh what the
idol animation is like all right cool
can do cool it's loading we are loading
right now all of us
yeah come on Dy all right so uh yeah
something's happening wait it's loading
it's loading someone wants to know what
the beta resolution is on the Xbox one I
think uh Bungie said yesterday that the
final game will be 1080p on Xbox one but
the beta isn't cuz they're
still optimizing yeah so this is my
character as you can see she's got a
pretty she's so blue pretty sweet
haircut yeah uh only one eye can kind of
actually see through she does have no
depth per and this is me dancing oh yeah
oh yeah ready good so good so good mhm
oh yeah she's getting her douge on and
already of course a bunch of people
people scurrying around here the
guardian situation I don't know why
they're not dancing these are just folks
who are also playing the beta we're
going to head on over to the postmaster
and pick up my mail cotti
55-30 what what kind of name is that oh
it's a robot companion app available
with the beta are we trying it out yeah
the companion app is downloadable right
now I haven't synced it yet um but I've
got it on my phone I'll start uh do you
have to sync it once you've downloaded
the uh I no here not yet I've got
it I will sign in you continue to do
this stuff I'll get my companion app
going so that was a little welcome note
from Bungie along with 500 glitter is
that what the it's not glitter it's
something glow sticks glow sticks what's
the currency called it for some reason
I'm thinking Glitter Glam dring Glam
drain yeah yeah glitter great that would
be so cool if that was the currency
glimmer glimmer glimmer yes
yeah all right glitter is not cool Mary
just gets stuck everywhere forever it's
the
grossest all right I'm going to go get
my equipment
on so if you guys never played the
Destiny Alpha this is the tower that
we're in right here this is kind of the
between missions Hub world where you get
you get outfitted with
gear uh you did I send you can purchase
new equipment and stuff like that uh all
right warlocks initiation Provisions for
newborn Guardians a set of warlock field
weave and a stash of glimmer not glitter
to improve it or buy other gear
okay uh get that glim let's see so you
all this is gear you can buy from her
and it's class specific gear yeah so
she's like the Warlock Merchant this
guy's got hunter equipment and woo
Frank t27 nice work this guy's the uh
the Titan like it's rude to stand on the
table you know it is you know what's
even more rude dancing on it Destiny
dancing on this dude's map oh man we
lasted about 20 minutes into this beta
before I jumped on a table and just
started dancing think I can like my
favorite move is actually to go for the
full recline the full recline yeah yeah
that's pretty good the just like lie
down on the table
what's my dance button yeah uh it's
right on the d-pad I think you can do
the d-pad is all like emotes emotes
yeah all right so this one's 18 defense
this one's 23 defense I believe that is
an upgrade uh there probably is there
was a level cap in the alpha I'm going
to assume in the alpha you went like
five like level three to level eight or
something yeah or 4 to eight they didn't
start you at level one like they are
doing in the beta here are there fly fly
in the game Flying like there's a
there's a hover bike we that we fly
there's a hover bike and then in terms
of flying like through the
air uh you know like more than a couple
feet above the ground I'm I'm sure there
will be but I don't know if they're
going to be in the beta so at this stage
the uh we're kind of going through the
tutorial right now where it's
introducing you to the different
merchants of the Tower so we are going
to go two ooh all right Auto rifle pulse
rifle o Scout rifle it's kind of a
sniper rifle and the Hand Cannon it's
more like a DMR yeah that's true more of
DMR I generally go assault rifle what do
you guys think your choice man my choice
it's your build I'll we'll choose other
things can we see them again one more
one more P Auto rifle pulse rifle Scout
rifle hand Cannon was the first one
Marsha the name of it Marshall a I like
that
I wish it was named Mar pronounced Mara
Mara
Mara pull out the old
Marsha now see you're getting on board
with the nicknames yeah
yeah but it's very normal to name your
gun a a person's name is as is like a
boat or a site ride or whip um all those
things are totally not made up yeah
normal to name but your enemy who is
clearly nonhuman mhm makes me
uncomfortable to give them human names
that's weird then I feel like I'm
shooting my buds I
mean oh okay hey that's fine I got no I
got no rebuttal that's how I feel you if
you have a friend named Doug and it
makes you feel weird to blast Dougs in
the face then that's something you're
just going to have to confront in your
life some people would like to know just
how your general feelings are of the
beta so far if you're impressed if you
know it's pretty much the same as the
alpha oh we've been playing for about 25
minutes now go on uh I I mean I really
like the alpha um and so far this has
not violently offended me in any way so
still feeling pretty positive about
Destiny word 10 yeah Arcadia class jump
ship jump ship jump ship anything surf
by the tower Shipyard this jump ship is
in much better shape than when it
arrived don't mind if I do that one
floating in the debris fields of the
five scrap
yards so this is where you go to get
your
ships repaired or just to get new ones
so there's different like yeah so CU you
have the ship that you jump from place
to place in but then you also
have uh the hover bike that you end up
cruising around in which I don't think
you have yet or maybe the ghost is just
able to conjure that thing there's so
many options sure off top of my head
Mary you've broken the 90% barrier yeah
I'm in 91% only Point only
960 megabytes left for you to download
in
the will your stats carry over to the
main game upon release I don't think so
there was an article on our site about
that actually we asked Bungie and they
said uh they didn't give a definitive
answer they said you know like it's
going to kind of depend on what kind of
data they get from the beta how it goes
what they you know what kind of changes
they think they need to make what kind
of rebalancing stuff I would guess not I
mean that seems to be generally the case
I would I would be surprised if that
happened cuz generally that doesn't
happen in it's pretty r that that
happens it's extremely rare that that
happens consider it a test run and use
it to make a better build next go so
we're off to do our first proper Mission
and as you can see we're uh old Russia
is kind of the only option at the moment
so that definitely seems to be the early
game environment I'd like to see the
other areas in the map we will be
observing later on well I don't think I
can do that yet I just want to see the
names of them no they're not even on
there oh you don't even know the world n
yeah not yet but you can't see the
different like provinces of Russia right
there's Gateway divide rocket yard Kings
watch Devil's lay moth yards Skywatch
forgotten Shore and then some area
called the blast The Moth yards I like
the I like moth yards so we're going to
do uh this particular mission right here
return to Fallen territory and hunt for
parts to restore your ship's ability for
interplanetary travel M shall we yes all
right oh away I did get a question
asking how long we will be streaming for
the answer is until we get hungry it is
about
12:15 I believe I had a granola bar
before the stream so it should be good
to go for I had some cereal in a jar
things are not looking good for Sean I
should have had one of those cereal bars
in my desk I have a little bit of Jar
cereal left if you would like some
precious jar cereal all right what is
this guy saying that cosmodrome is the
only place I know where we might still
find one we survived the Fallen ones we
can do it
again dinkle ghost believes in you Sean
oh thanks thanks here
Dinklage than all right my J
day running really low Dan brought
snacks so we don't have to scavenge
Mary's jar
cereal I have water do you guys need
yeah I could use some
water all right hey you've got there's
some P here dud dudes dudes dudes what's
up dudes where you guys going come here
pink truffles you guys want to Buddy up
or what you just going to go to town on
these so this appears to be the same
place this this appears to be the alpha
starting point yeah this was the
starting point which means you can go
into the basement go into the secret
basement and
find you guys remember these super
kickass dudes from the alpha I assume
they're still in here and fixing to
murder me in 2 seconds FL oh you're not
do you have a yeah there we go there we
go what is jar cereal it is cereal that
I put in a jar here we go so if you guys
played the alpha yeah you go down into
the canal if you guys play the Alpha
maybe you went down into this building
it's like right at the beginning you go
down into this basement into this canal
M and then you can do some exploring and
get murdered just instantly I feel like
they were the other direction think so I
thought they were like
immediately immediately greet you in
this like murky sewer down supposed to
go oh there we go so his his level is
double question marks which means that
he's super high level and is going to no
he knows he saw you all right this H
night all right youring skills are show
you just yeah so that's Bam Bam like
that that's how high level he is those
dudes SE they put this little area right
at the very beginning almost to like
taunt you for like the level and the
progression absolutely to TA you have to
put into the game before you can take on
these dudes yeah so yeah which is fine
it's fine got real worked
over so my buddies have taken off
without me not that they were ever truly
my buddies begin they wer they were
nobody's buddies your only friend is
Ghost uh dinkle ghost dinkle and uh just
a bunch of Dougs bunch of Dougs it's me
and some Doug
Pals Doug
Pals these Dougs are my only friend
these a couple Vinnies oh yeah a couple
Vinnies and a shank if you missed it
before Dougs and Vinnies are the names
you're calling the drag and Vandal
enemies uh that sea is facing now
because it makes me uncomfortable to
give them
it makes Mar very uncomfortable which
was an unanticipated bonus of giving
them
nicknames um what do you think is in the
sewer that they're preventing you to go
and do you think like when you're high
enough level you will go back and try to
kill them hell
yeah but I can call their last trans
this was not in the alpha so it's even
though
we done this area before it's richer
now I would say it's richer and more
compelling
uh meanwhile I've been trying to log
into the companion app and it's not
happening unable to load the signin page
down in the tunnels below we should
check it out oh meanwhile I'm loaded
just fine and on the companion app it
shows my level two warlock shes yeah
some people want to know if the AI is
better since the alpha I don't know just
yet a little too early little too early
to decide I mean well get a get an
example from the twitch chat what did
they have any issues with the AI in the
alpha yeah what what yeah yeah let's be
let's be specific here guys they said
they found it a little disappointing
they or just Bob Jones 1980 cuz nothing
can nothing can ever truly please Bob
Jones as it
does the chat speaks as a hive mind oh
Bob
Jones yeah this has got all your
inventory stuff going on here I can I
can maybe are you going to change my
inventory while I'm playing mess up your
sub CL here oh no no I can't you have to
be level 15 okay for people just joining
again and wondering why we're not
playing uh we are installing it it
is an almost 11 gig
download that a lot of people are trying
to download simultaneously so the the
servers are slammed so Sean's got his
downloaded mine's at 67% Mary's is at
92% yep um when we're all in we're kind
of just going to switch to whoever is
doing the most interesting thing it'll
or we should actually party up too yeah
no he won't be he won't be that much
overleveled than you we're not going to
party up in this extremely multiplayer
focused shooter Mary's not having it
Mary's not interested in partying up I'm
going to manage your items all right all
I just equipped a different gun for you
did you
yeah I so what's the other one called
not the marshala the kostov I I chose to
equip that so I don't know if it'll just
keep playing see if it happens switch to
your switch to your secondary and switch
back to your primary is the companion
app on Android a map of the entire or is
it iPhone it's probably not going to
happen mid mid thing I don't know I
would assume they would have gone with
IOS and Android it seems a little
cruel what we really need to find is a
warp drive you have to purchase a PS4
and an iPhone in order to enjoy it sure
they have our only hope is where we
found our ship we have to go back all
right you got to go back and kill you
have to go back to the future to the
sewers to the to the Future sewers you
got nothing in your Vault you got
nothing in your inventory literally just
started so boring you got no strike
stats you got no current bounties I have
hell of bounties Chris mm- oh it's so
dark I can't see anything you really
don't oh cool am I walking into a wall
turn on your
or does it automatically turn on it
automatically turns on just like cars of
the
future auto headlights auto
headlights the dinkle ghost can you like
like the brightness on the monitor that
we're playing on is like for some reason
turned way down also we have bright
lights in our eyes can't actually see
anything is that where I'm supposed to
go yep you're doing fine yeah
just how much is it to
pre-order well Bonito could you come in
here and turn up the brightness on on
this TV I can do it all right I think
it's turn up the brightness on the
monitor I think it's pretty bright
already one second guys we're going to
turn up the brightness on this monitor a
little
bit uh picture just hard to see in the
yeah just crank that up to like 70 all
right I got
it that a little better yeah that's good
should be
good then left it on what do you mean
just play it says aspect okay there you
go now you can see okay no excuses sorry
for the technical difficulties
everybody oh look why always got to be
so technically difficult I couldn't so I
I before I couldn't actually see that
there was a set of stairs here the
brightness on that TV was just turned
all the way down oh he got some duggies
eat that Dougies look at those numbers
those Dougies got fried you made them
number it up
yeah ooh face
pal do you collect anything from the
dead
bodies uh you can get ammo a you just
waved at FPS hater 101 and now you guys
are having a dance party that's so cute
oh he stabbed
you you are showing
subm yeah the magic of made a friend
yeah he's dancing in your put his butt
in your face he's put his butt right in
your is there a way for us to he stabbed
you hey dude Bud up with me I think you
can can you friend him what was the so
like you can say hi
mhm that was that the up on the d-pad
for
emote yeah
that's like a go to this glowing thing
over here someone wants to know if we
can name
resources can you name the ghost yeah
yeah dinkle ghost yeah dinkle ghost we
just named it dinkle ghost formally you
can name anything if you believe in
yourself can you formally name it I mean
that was pretty formal when we came up
with dinkle ghost
Yeah in our hearts and
Minds oh get you some Vector oath some
new oh yeah it's it's options not the
touch me you got all right 18 defense
you got some some better gauntlets man
if it keeps up like this Chris you oh
yellow gauntlets way into these
gauntlets scanning for the warp driveing
forever bad news it's already in Fallen
hands damn it dinkle ghost I hope you're
ready for this I have entered a Darkness
Zone if you die in a Darkness Zone you
will be return to the start of
it my whole life is one big Darkness
Zone yeah if you'll be he'll respawn at
the beginning of your life if you die
that's so sad this is Sea's way that he
believes in
reincarnation peekaboo peekabo ya whoa
where did those guys I feel like there
were more of them that just appeared now
do you think these guys are also in a
Darkness zone or are they just Dead
Forever when they
die it's really hard to tell with Dougs
yeah and Vinny's there's a grenade right
next to you you walk right onto it yeah
I most certainly did all right let's
charge up the old Health did you go back
to the beginning of the darkness Zone on
your own yeah that was a voluntary
Darkness Zone
Retreat that one was all me
guys yeah what are those things called
again Shanks Shanks we haven't given
them a people name yet Mary so if you'd
like to do the honors no let's just call
them Shanks Shirley there it is no oh
devil
Aron recharge yelling okay guys guys
we're good we're good let's
calmly going to take care of that Vinnie
right there good good call spin out the
vines yeah spin out the
VIN your health regen oh my health is
fine feeling strong you got aade you got
a Grenade on tap do I what's up a brick
uh hiding behind I don't see any numbers
oh there were some numbers you're a
number you're aren't we all oh look a
bonus vent getting dark again boo that
is really oh you gotp attack do not do
not try to melee that guy you got melee
dudes that are twice your height Lon
learn on twice your
arms and squashed your head yeah that
dude has bonus
arms all
right how's my ammo situation good
you're doing
fine should be able to take down rushi
over there no
problem Rush all right so it seems as
though there are bonus Vinnies who are
coming in here more time I spend on this
boss I agree I would just go for the
boss they're going to keep
spawning oh gosh devil archon oh eat it
eat it yeah eat it you got an NLS drive
out of that that's for using the
National Library
service thanks National Library service
I enjoy your
books Serpentine motions yeah look at
these little sine wave I'm coming for
you I'm Coming For
You
squash Noe nope passing back and forth
nice slaps you had a slap fight you got
an encrypted engram and house banners
this could [__] fall and we got a
warp drive
I have to get you to the speaker dinkle
ghost is very proud of you dinkle ghost
is uh he's uh he's Stern but fair he
will let you know the father you never
had like the father I never
had just kidding I I totally have a dad
I have I have a father Mission
ended made some progress towards your
other things looks like you have other
grenade options that you're going to be
working on unlocking you got a like
another helmet I think that is yeah
that's good cuz I was still using the uh
the first helmet they fire
3 the ceremonial hoods of the first
warlocks directed attention to their
words rather than their identities
M Mary you're at 94% I am at 94% we
might just be able to see the intro
cinematic which is a thing yeah let's
not get excited yet all right slow down
it's taking a good 10 minutes for me to
get that 4% actually slow it down and
just a reminder that we are totally
giving away Destiny beta keys today
during the stream all you have to do is
go to the Gamespot comments leave a
comment on why you want a code and
you'll be entered to win one the codes
that we'll be giving are going to be
redeemable for PlayStation and Xbox
platforms both last and current gen uh
the only difference being PlayStation
platforms can access the game now Xbox
dudes have to wait but now there's a cut
there was a
time cut when we were much more
powerful but that was long
ago until it wakes and Finds Its
voice I am the one who speaks for the
traveler you must have no end of
questions
Guardian in its dying breath The
Traveler created the ghosts to seek out
those who can wield its light as a
weapon
Guardians to protect us and do what the
traveler itself no longer
can what happened to
it I could tell you of the great battle
centuries
ago how the traveler was
crippled I could tell you of the power
of the darkness its ancient
enemy there are many tales told
throughout the city to frighten
children lately those Tales have
stopped
now the children are frightened
anyway scared kids long darkness is
coming
back we will not survive it this time
it's armies surround us the Fallen are
just the
beginning what can I
do you must push back the
darkness Guardians are fighting on Earth
and
Beyond join them your ghost will guide
you I only hope he chose wisely
I did I'm sure of
it we're in this together
now it cannot identify that actor sounds
so familiar anybody in the chat room
have any guesses who that that actor
is
I'm in the twitch chat he's that old guy
oh that old guy that old
guy all right Sean level three way to go
buddy level three Neato burrito Don't
Mind If I Do Nolan
North definitely not North Peter North
William defo you guys are just saying
names now William come on guys Morgan
Freeman Peter North might be no wait
that's a porn star oh
no yeah oh no yeah that's a definitely a
porn star oh uh I think I'm going to go
to the Tower and get my Ingram decrypted
cuz those look like they wa you need
some sick boots I need those Sicky
boots those boots are These Boots Were
Made for
Walking Nathan they were made for
dancing Peter store Lance reic storari
whatever Nathan fillian Tomic sh over
here he's like the famous one it's not
Nathan fillian he's so famous yeah he's
not on that list I checked IMDb they
only list five actors that one
is ah whatever I'm not going to be able
to think of it push it just straight out
of your mind okay loading screen load
that screen up it's going into the Vault
what is this what do you think of this
ship this ship is the kind of ship that
was like Hey this design is kind of neat
but it's really incentivizing me to get
a different looking ship it's a it's a
inoffensive very vanilla warp ship and I
think that eventually as time goes on
you'll get things such as like a sweet
tiger print warp ship can I get a
spoiler for it you could probably get a
sick spoiler for it can I get some
Spinners yeah I'm sure you could yeah I
my ship if my if I can't warp on dubs
then I'm not interested be quiet I have
to chat with Master Rahul you got
it hello oo don't mind if I do so I get
a little glimmer bonus for collecting
those house banners way back when I
suspected you'd choose that one and I'm
going to decrypt this Ingram looks very
solid Guardian all right Enigma burn
Boots St safe turn put on your boots Put
on your sick boots I'm putting on my my
boots Put on your Enigma boots oh those
are oh requ they're too complicated for
you to put on your feet I'm almost at
level These Boots are very those boots
are laces and you can only do vcro these
are very complicated boots
Chris oh but you can do a Glide now
don't mind if I do I love the Glide
ability not smart enough for
boots how dare you Chris all right how
much stick with your velcro
boots how much glimmer do I have where
does it show my glimmer situation
ation it's in the top right under is it
135 yeah there we go you got 135 glimmer
Stacks I'm doing pretty good all right
let's go to orbit let's go back and do a
mission yeah let get now that I got my
boots decrypted now that Mary's at 96%
and I'm at 79% proving that I am moving
at a faster rate so you had to to what
did you have to do to be able to put
your boots on it wasn't that it was too
high of a level it's like an it's like
an RPG you have nonidentified
items scroll he had to identify them but
then it turned out they were too high
level for to put on but at least you
know what they are now yes at least
you're aware that they're boots CU
they're very complex boots that's very
clear that's the mission I just did
let's go off and do this one investigate
reports of a hidden power trapped in the
cosmo Drome array station what's the
other one
available that's level four story break
the house of Devil's grasp on the
cosmodrome and secure a vital link to
the golden
age uh go for level three yeah let's go
level three I think I want to say that
this is the uh the mission from the
beginning of the Alpha maybe could be
possibly maybe I don't know the one with
the wizard from the
Moon that wizard came from the Moon your
dinkle ghost impersonation is terrible
that wizard came from the Moon a Prett
TI is a moon
Wizard or it could be something
the speaker is asking Guardians to look
into
it Mary you've been stuck at 96% for a
dog's age a while I'm at 80 now Gap he's
been slow on the other side of the steps
and it's surrounded by so this is from
the alpha is this all familiar this is
the intro Miss familiar to me yeah can
you use a hover
bike no no you don't have a hover bike
yet those boots were made for walking
and that's just what you'll
do oh no your friend got killed oh
no no he was one week until retirement
oh man I'll never know his
name the traditional Earth burial
respect maneuver the uh morning Squad so
we seen aester Mission that's more than
one to three fire team
oh look at that I think the max fire
team is three I think it is too that's
the only thing we've seen so far at
least yeah that's true so if it's more
we haven't seen it probably going to be
able to run with bigger Crews you guys
think I can glide across this little c i
got
this oh easy yeah with room to spare you
are lofty yeah you are loving that it
that seems a little bit does it seem a
little bit boostie than it did it does
booer than the AL seems like it lasts a
little bit
longer cuz in the alpha it was basically
like a double jump almost but here it's
like gliding for days yeah that seems
definitely increased you don't have a
meter though that lets you know when
you're out of juice it I do it's it
lives inside of my heart ah yeah I go by
my gut Mary that's your heart's in your
gut yeah wait youry is terrible I have a
birth condition
I don't want to talk about it it's
called gut heart called gut heart it's
like you've never met somebody with a
case of the gut heart it's actually more
one in seven people have it I didn't
know it was so common yeah it's not as
strange as you would think mhm I'm not a
doctor oh what's
up surprise that guy is terrible at
hiding oh poor guy there's a cave in
this on this wall on the right look up
to the left are we going to try out
Death Match there I think that's a maybe
mayhaps I have not unlocked The Crucible
yet yeah you got to unlock these didn't
make it but I did make it onto this sick
ledge it's pretty good right okay we
good just like those goats just like
those goats that
climb incredible
Heights yes those are called wal
goats wal goats wal goats they use wall
hacks I don't believe any oh that's a
level seven drag oh you are maybe don't
engage with those guys or you know use
tactics or have friends with you you
know me Chris you know my stance on
tactics why do you have your shotgun out
it's jump down in there and Get Saucy oh
that's a that's pretty good move oh they
found you
recharge all right
so as you can see your health recharges
to the
Next Level
briefly what up oh you're getting cocky
now oh
yeah so you're only getting still plus
20 for those straight
kills a cave you know what shotgun seems
this seems like a shotgun situation it
also seems like a I'm going to die inant
whoa question mark guys that means a
void we we learned that less we don't
like question mark guys if you don't
know you can't you got to go I mean
there's a reason you got to go I like
that yours Rhymes I like that one better
yeah we have to have rhyming when it
comes to pneumonics like that if you
don't know you got to
go all right yeah off to the right here
that also means that you might want to
remember that spot and come back later
cuz there's probably some juicy stuff
for you oh
yeah like juice like Poss literal
juice oh man you love SL people I love
the melee attack it's so satisfying it
is just like a talk to the hand
Splat the hunter melee attack is a knife
stab you want to Duke it out with that
dude okay shot his head off yeah you're
going to shot on the crap out of that
yeah oh look at how he died that's he
died as he lived dance on his body
contorted in agony on his
corpse yeah yeah way better than
teabagging I'm more offended than I
would be sit down on his body that's
what I'm going I'm going to become one
with him just really know youve laid
with him I know him in the biblical
sense
now that's not what that
means I don't think you've ever read
that
book I uh I read the the YouTube
summary watch the Youtube summary watch
YouTube Bible yeah that guy's dead Big
Time dead I was a little bit
overkilled whoa Captain Ron you get back
here
is Captain Ron the uh the Kurt Russell
uh pirate movie yes that's what I think
well not a pirate movie but like he's
like a cool Captain guy he is he's got
one eyeball the other one is a fake
glass one and he takes a family on a
journey it's kind of like UHC from New
York it's kind of like a family what is
it called like um it's kind of like
Christmas vacation or any of those
National Lampoon National vacationed
where it's like a family with like a
this was one of SK station they go
through crazy in to the lunar
colonies some people are asking um how
they get codes you just put a comment in
the Gamespot chat and they're wondering
how long the stream is we'll be here as
long as we can hold out
um because we will need to eat I'd say
within 15 minutes you or 20 minutes Mary
and I stand a good chance of getting in
there yeah I'm excited Mary's Mary's
getting close 97% she's been getting
close for a long time though this last
this last 10% has been brutal it's my
actually caught up I'm at 85 now but do
you think your last 10% is also going to
be brutal I I have finishing strength in
fact you have finishing strength if you
can catch up to me any quicker we could
do this together and Buddy Buddy much
quicker we can fire team and then take
Shawn down yeah well that's the ultimate
goal of the live our destiny yeah that's
no that's not what that no don't shake
on it don't guys don't shake on it it's
going to happen please don't shake on it
enjoy the now while you
can we are going to dance the [__] out
of you you think you're the only one who
can dance look at those Barnacles bad
about oh this is the moon wizard part
shoot
it came from the
Moon guys it's bad news so dark it is
Bad News Bears right now whoa all right
you guys want a piece of this The Hive
the plowey Booyah he jumped on your face
you can just melee you should have Mele
could there's some range on that melee
in case you're wondering a little bit of
range you got some long
arms eat it they took a little bit of
your health yeah your shotgun ammo is
running a little low certainly
is oh yeah dramatic music
situation oh what up
acolyte they got little lights on their
heads that kind of give them away a
little bit yeah
that's how you know it's an
Alvin Alvin that's what we're calling
the alites I don't know that's I I've
been making up all the names here if you
don't want you want to come up with one
yourself feel free I'm doing the heavy
lifting on this stream you certainly
there's a wizard here coming up with
silly nicknames there's a wizard here
you have to guys we're going to find out
if that line is still where did that
wizard come from I think he says it
after you kill it I think so
yeah
oh my God something happened what Mar I
think Mary's completed her down think my
game but I don't have a
controller oh that's probably a thing
you need Bonito guys can we get Mary a
controller you didn't bring it over I
was charging oh okay it's the one on top
I'm sure it's on top by the
TV pretty sure
that's all are kind of nasty ooh I got a
new
Ingram all right the Wizard's here yeah
he is oh it's wizard time get
whizzed nobody beats the whiz except for
all Destiny players I think I might also
have to increase oh
[__] oh no Darkness
Zone oh did you get Darkness consumed
the darkness consumed me oh this was not
a thing that happened in the alpha yeah
in the alpha you could get killed by
that wizard T of
times there it is flowy all right don't
get cocky don't get cocky yeah play it
safe I was holding on to the computer so
that you didn't knock it over by
accident thank you teamw work that was
nice making the dream
work come on Sean you got this got this
I know
what their head shots are different they
explode in like yellow
fireworks all right I am
in okay all right while Shawn continues
this battle against the wizard which you
guys have probably seen from the alpha
we're going to switch over to Mary's
character creation all right let's do it
and you're going to choose your class
Shan's the Warlock so take your pick of
Titan or Hunter all right let's go go
over what they do a little bit uh
Striker smash the ground and dissolve
enemies and Defender shape void light
into an indestructible Shield you said
he was more like a he's kind of a tank
tank and then the hunter Gunslinger
summon a flaming pistol which
disintegrates enemies with solar light
well that's pretty good MH blade dancer
charge your Blade with Ark light and
consume your foes with lightning well
both of those sound just awesome you're
going for the hunter so I'm going to do
Hunter nice I played the hunter in the
uh beta or the alpha rather and that
light gun is pretty dang
fun so you got your your race is you
have the human the awoken and the EXO
shano's an awoken I believe yes he did
because that is those Crystal Blue Eyes
the EXO is a straight up Robo peoples
and then the humans I think I'm going to
go with Robo go Robo Robo that means
that Chris has to do a uh human I'll do
a human I'll make big Hank fake
um my skin color you are a straight up
Gundam right now holy crap look at your
face it looks good yeah it's cool what
are the other ones let's see just take
us to our tour RoboCop
yep my red eyes are so intense I think I
might try to give them a little come
back come back come back come back to me
common green come back to me come back
to my screen oh okay goodbye so your
mission just ended we should probably
get moving did he say the thing
oh he didn't say it he didn't say uh
there's a there's a chest here if you
jump up I think behind
you up on there yeah try jump go hurry I
think there's a chest back there or at
least there wasn't we're asking to come
back to this screen okay never mind to
see if he would say that wizard came
from the moon but he didn't actually say
say that wizard came from the Moon all
right so Sean's going to go back and
maybe do some uh kit upgrade stuff yeah
I've got some some good stuff and we'll
check out Mary's face how's your face
situation coming uh yeah I've started to
adapt my face features I can have these
horn my Mohawk yep um
antenna multiple antenna that's just
like those are like the Sonicare
toothbrushes sticking out of your head
kind of like those those look like I
have Dre beets on yeah um was pretty Co
one of the few products to survive the
centuries that one's a straight up hole
on your head you can like move the
analog stick to the left and right I
think to or the other one the right
stick to turn your head is that true no
I made that up you did I would like to
see it from different
angles that's a pretty o Robo spikes are
good Robo spikes um those are like those
straps that people put on their clothes
but they go on your headers yeah head
suspenders head suspenders go with
spikes go with Robo spikes that's like a
headbutt plate
those there are a couple different Robo
spikes there's so many Robo spikes oh
those are good I like not those you
don't like my antennas those are like
some anime stuff I feel like Sailor Moon
has those or something what about the
hole in the head oh that's good I like
that one all
right done the Triceratops the tri sort
of Triceratops for Rob Duo ceratops can
have a marking currently
it's it's just really just have a bunch
of junk on your
face yeah blue
stripe done he he looks good I think
you're set styling I think you're
satisfied yeah you're good uh so this is
going to be the opening cinematic some
of which was in the alpha like the
description of yeah so we'll let's some
of it is new I think I don't know if
there's audio might turn it up I'm sure
they have audio what about I mean you
don't have audio for like you to listen
to but I'll keep it low so we're not
competing
here we're good T I got it she she did
it yeah thank you Eric Tay ladies and
gentlemen Eric Tay man of the
people Lim are you asserting that I
don't know don't watch Sailor Moon yeah
you're correct one small step for man oh
they're on Mars one giant leap
sick for Hunter
classes happened when they went to
Mars looking for
life it used military hand
signals oh these guys are trekking all
across
Mars and they have an assault rifle
because that's what astronauts on Mars
need to bring they must know something's
here why else would an astronaut have an
assault rifle which one is Buzz
Aldren which one is he's the trigger
happy one Robo Buzz he's the one who's
that guy was always a loose cannon he's
the Wild Card ooh yes they found the
traveler they
did
very epic
true which one is Sandra Bullock someone
wants to know traveler and George Clint
arrival changed us
forever great cities were built on Mars
and Venus Mercury became a garden World
human lifespan tripled
it was a time of
Miracles we stared out at the Galaxy and
knew that it was our destiny to walk in
the light of other
stars but the traveler had an enemy that
might be Peter storm a
darkness which had hunted it for eons
across the black Gulfs of space
centuries after our golden age began
this Darkness found us
and that was the end of
everything no I don't think that's but
it was also beginning a
beginning maybe it is I don't know
scintillating commentary for me I
know
was L
Year all right here we go so this is the
very beginning right before uh what sea
did at the beginning of the stream this
is what
happened you know we said this before in
the alpha but it is just
stunning it is really good looking just
a gorgeous
gorgeous
I'm in
Russia old Russia old Russia in the
future that's Peter
Dinklage dinkle ghost as we call
him you're at 9
okay Hing for
life and
Mer angry
guys
is this
possible there you
are
Guardian guardian eyes up
Guardian it
worked you're
alive you don't know how long I've been
looking for you you Chris you're at 95%
I'm so
now I'm so Peter well you've been dead a
long time so you're going to see a lot
of things you won't
understand this is Fallen territory we
aren't safe here I have to
get hold
still don't worry I'm still with you we
need to move
fast
all right so Mary is now at the very
beginning of the playable part at 95%
open like this let's get I know this
would be cruel to ask but do you want to
hang out there for a little bit and not
make too much progress so that we can
fire team up short sure sure now do are
we allowed to team up from the very
beginning uh yeah you probably can't
until you get to the Tower For the First
Time cool so yeah so I have to go
through this beginning piece why don't
you go through this till you can get to
the Tower all right all right um it also
gave me a little bit of time to warm up
um cuz unlike Sean and Chris I never
played the alpha I never got my hands on
it so this is my first experience with
Destiny pretty excited how does it feel
to be attacked by a shadow bird oh my
God yeah so while Mary goes through this
uh intro stuff that we actually showed
sha do at the beginning of the stream
we're going to bop on over to Shawn and
see where he's at what kind of
did you do like a gear upgrade here
buddy yeah yeah so I uh
took so I went back to my uh Vanguard I
forget the name but the the class
specific people who give you items
whatever yeah you got some hats yeah and
so I had the choice of getting like a
really nice highlevel helmet uh Gauntlet
or chest armor and I went with a helmet
because each one had a different perk to
it and this one one is grenade hits
restore melee energy is that
active like it looks like it's shaded
like it's shaded yeah press the triangle
like it like
the uh the perk itself oh causing damage
with a grenade reduces your
no what is that so
like what does that mean so because if
you go if you go over the helmet it
looks like that it's like it can have
that perk but because oh like you have
to unlock that seems like to me so if
you go to details then what is what do
these two circles say cuz that's the
that's the icon the grenade icon
right so strength recre is the cool down
of your energy drain what's that is that
your m is that your anyways causing
damage with the grenade reduces your
melee cool down so that's a perk can you
click on that why does it say glimmer it
just looks like maybe using it like like
that green circle around the edge of it
in other cases has indicated like
experience right or you know usage yeah
yeah so we'll see maybe it'll it'll
increase as you as you go and use it I
guess uh let's see here all right so I
can finally unlock my super which is the
Nova bomb yeah don't mind if I do so I
uh jumped into the kind of like free
roaming Mission here which is where you
have the environment and it does these
kind of like procedurally generated
missions I think uhhuh um I could so
there's a way point there there's
another one there you're getting blasted
by someone where are
they there whoa waa it's that guy it's a
ship maybe oh you died yeah you you you
ran him off yeah I scared that guy not
in my backyard uh so I could keep doing
this or I could go to a story Mission
think I should do that story
Mission story sounds sounds interesting
to me but just do one of these guys real
quick you're right here just go to go to
one of these beacons it'll probably just
be like kill a bunch of dudes but who
knows I'm interested to see what one of
these is and then you can go to the
story one these so these missions are
here as kind of like they regenerate and
they're kind of basic like you know kill
off all these bad guys collect all these
things and it's kind of there to serve
as like little in between opportunities
for the story missions it seems like so
you can actually like grind a little bit
and just level up and try out your armor
outside of like a big critical Story
Mission or something like that okay all
right so like this one is I'm actually
just scouting
enemies did I just show your stomach
what did you I think I did uhoh it might
need to it might be time might be time
to bust out bar you want to pass one of
those this way want a granola bar Sean
yeah here you go yeah oh this one's
slightly melted yeah I'm going to put it
on the couch that's because they've been
sitting between my butt and Mary's butt
oh great which is a real incubation
situation butt
incubation as they
say scouting some enemies heading
through this area I know this
area so you're just following the little
carrot on your
um radar on the top left
oh SP dudes in here
before whoa Mary do you have a rifle I
do all
right so let's just HP over to Mary real
quick was that your starting weapon no
it was not oh really it was not where'd
you find it um I got it right after I
got my other weapon so I believe I
triangle to change my weapon here's my
starter weapon that I first got and then
really quickly I would say I obtained
this sniper rifle so for the hunter
class you get your starting assault
rifle then this sniper rifle but for the
Warlock class Sean you got a shotgun
very quickly afterwards right yeah the
shotgun was my first alternate weapon
yeah oh yeah went through their
bodies I believe I got a
twofer makes sense right in the crotch
that was serious crot crotch them heads
nice job Mary oh thank you that's about
it not too many exciting things going on
but I did get a rifle
here this guy drop some
good
yeah whoops don't kill me please I don't
have too many bullets with this guy so
I'm going to switch
back other weapon because I
have
Bullets My turning is weird it's going
full
turn never go full turn no I
mean can I jump up here come on a didn't
make it all right Hang on we're watching
Mary what do you think all right we're
not watching Mary let's go back to sea
he's still trying to scout some enemies
there's something wrong I got to go up
to my scouting perk what's the matter um
it's oh hey Chris look at
you
yeah you see it so it's rotating all the
way instead of a little bit this is
weird whole controller situation is
weird right now let's get you a
different
controller it just started doing it when
I switched guns is this getting like
interference this is super weird we try
another controller controller from Mar
all right so you guys chose Hunter and
warlock so that means I'm going to
choose a Titan
yep oh look at this sick
loot um no it's there's something wrong
with
it I just need another one controller
wonk it's really just it's going weird
is there I think there's another
controller over there there's a
controller on my desk if we need no
there's another one right there are you
guys going back
oh just
circle so
Chris finally finished downloading the
game and he is also on the character
creation now and he is making uh hunky
McGee it looks like no that's that's
Bono that's
um not synced a yeah that's you just
synced it press Circle to cancel
please uh you just you that's the wrong
box you to
switch no cuz that just synced it with
oh some stranger just revived me oh
that's so nice of them thanks dude
bro um let's see let's just try hold on
let's try turning this uh you could
restart let's try try turning off the
controller turning back on back
on controller malfunctions this
controller is seriously freaking out
like the button presses are not
responding yes that's the one that's the
correct
box Alo just press X and bring it over
here so maybe press X and then you'll be
able to use
the Sean what are you doing over there
buddy what you I'm doing this uh enemy
scouting Mission at the moment you take
the lead Sean okay well uh what I got to
do is I'm hanging out on the top of this
roof here or rooftop if you will and uh
I'm just trying to Scout as many enemies
as I can it's kind of like a little
Intel
Mission and then once I Scout him I kill
him cuz that's what you do you have a
cable that you could
connect no but you have a longer cable
that we could keep it
connected uh all right press try to
press circle out of
there n okay so hold
on what is
this
yeah I crushed my controller Mary has
destroyed the controller what did you
find Sean b
claws provide an accurate estimate of
enemy power in the Divide is
the little mission that I'm doing right
now all right
and I finish that one no cool I'm
sending everything home to the tower it
might be the
game that's what's happening I'm turning
it's going it's
delayed why don't you quit out of the
game and load it back up see what's
happening it's not
right no I mean it's cuz it's not
responding with alacrity inside of the
menu
either
yeah all right so I just did that little
Mini Mission there I'm going to go back
into orbit so that I can uh start the
next Story
Mission cool cuz those tend to be a bit
more
exciting I'm making a dude named big
Hank he's a Titan so he's a handsome man
actually he has to be
big he likes to accessorize yeah not
afraid to accessorize I like how his
skin and his hair and his eyebrows are
all the same color yeah he's camouflaged
and also super
goth definitely
not do you want to try finding not is
there one of these controllers on your
desk yeah I'm can you check Sean's desk
and grab an actual one of these guys a
different one the desk by the
window eye color golden yellow cat eyes
I don't know that's pretty
handsome oh he looks you've made a
handsome man I'm saying here
so um this is the mission select screen
here I've already done this one I have
done this one as well this one's it's
too high level for me I uh level six
this is level six and I'm currently
level four but there is a level four
story mission available so that's what
I'm going to do right
now
happened you want to try to reboot the
PS4 yeah I W you like power it down
completely like unplug the power
cable don't have to start from scratch I
wonder if it'll save at all it should it
should stay save at server you made
Justin Bieber let go back you like my be
nice be first a pretty sweet
be is there red undertones under that be
I think it's just reflecting off my scar
I don't
know I actually really liked this look
yeah yeah give him different hair color
though all right wait hold on I actually
didn't check out the different face
types oh no yeah come on that's a big
Hank right there now this is my big
Hank that's pretty that's a long face oh
that's a good one that's pretty pretty
strong I think you got to you got to go
with this one you like this one over
blonde hair give him blonde hair you
want them to be like swed yeah ooh
that's lip color don't give him yellow
lips could you give him a little bit of
color in his lips though feel like he's
got jaundice going on him like a little
bit of pink yeah a little pink little uh
no don't no don't make his lips yeah
there you go too pink oh yeah that's a
good one no look you guys gross you guys
don't understand the chapped situation
that these guys good that's good that's
good
yeah all right I'm doing my story
Mission not a good
sign the controller is
delayed o white hair white hair is
pretty good give me a second well I'm
trying to figure out what it is give me
a second did you find the other
controller
Bonito can you hold on just can you like
plug it in Mary can you turn this
controller
off all right cool I'll let you guys
handle
it look at all these different candy
colored hair types I can give this dude
I cotton candy this big Hank is not
really a colorful hair type guy like he
you should just make a human we got a
robot we got a wild I don't know what
you
are woken a woken blue-haired
woken there you go that's
it uh not need a
marking oh Dead Eye damn look at that
Dead Eye that's a good one that's pretty
good sloppy finger paints nah I don't
know what that is that's like some
Pythagorean stuff right there oh that's
good skullman skull SK skull dude Bob
skullman Bob
skullman wow these are bold I I'm going
dead eyee man they're pretty int you can
change the color of his Dead Eye can I
yeah oh nice gross make it red make it
Red Dead Eye doesn't have red red
there's orange my scarf yeah
yeah green green no go orange orange is
pretty bold yeah way to have a dead eye
Dead
Eye uh someone would like you to have
hair highlights guys I don't mean to
brag but I just got M Sparrow oh sea is
running around on a motorbike I got my
creamsicle eyeball I don't know about
creamsicle let's go back to Shawn and
see his
motorbike